our correspondent Nick Conley who is in
Ukraine can join us now on the line
again he is in the east of the country
near the country's second biggest city
Nick what can you tell us what's the
latest from Ukraine
I'm here in a small town in region about
150 kilometers away from kramatosk which
is the administrative capital of Ukraine
held on basket she has also come in for
a lot of uh attacks seemingly today
explosions reported there as you
mentioned Ukraine's biggest second
biggest city which is only 50 kilometers
away from the Russian border about a
hundred kilometers into my North so
north of where I am now
um definitely a sense that the initial
day kind of wonderment of most people
you when I got off the train this
morning most people just go staring at
their phones and couldn't quite believe
what was happening has now shifted and
people are getting worried there was a
big cue the people in front of the bank
trying to withdraw cash from the ATM and
just heard that that ATM is now empty
all the cash being withdrawn people
trying to get fuel in case they need to
leave
um big cues at the petrol stations for
that and we've seen people in uniforms
and various kinds of Emergency Services
stocking up on water and other supplies
and telling us that they're heading east
towards Don bass they've been called up
and police
quite nervous
local control they heard big explosions
while it was still dark they assumed
that comes from Ukrainian military
airfields under attack close to the
Russian border I've heard a distant
start which we're seeing leaves from
artillery are quite a distance and
definitely heard what sounds like jet
aircraft in the sky couldn't see them
but could hear them they definitely
sound very different civilian planes so
people just very very worried and not
really clear what they should be doing
most people probably they don't have
anywhere to go not as if they have a
plan b or somewhere else they can go and
also ask themselves when they're going
to hear more from the government people
here Group by doing that but they're not
getting clear instructions from Kiev yet
but on the other hand you know people
here are used to walk through that
conflict in eastern Ukraine has been
going on for eight years so that is it's
not their first experience it will
albeit now on a totally different scale
with those reports of Russian troops
coming from Belarus from the south and
Black Sea so an an intervention or
totally different scale but still uh or
a situation that people in Ukraine are
familiar with and have experienced in
the past eight years
uh Nick you said that people that you
are seeing there in that region are
being called up to go to Don bass
presumably to defend Ukraine can we
expect the Ukrainian military and
reservists now to launch an A
counter-attack or resistance to resist
uh provide armed resistance to the
attack from Russia
these are people in uniform these are
people from uh kind of Emergency
Services kind of uh fire fire brigade
that kind of thing being called up so it
wasn't like these were civilians yet but
I think it's important to remember that
there are up to half a million people
here in Ukraine who have served in that
war in donbath of the last eight years
it's a very very big number of people
who have extensive military experience
for whom being called up and who you
know would not be something unexpected
or totally unfamiliar who bring with
them skills and experience
um I think you know no one really here
thinks that Ukraine is going to try and
fight a kind of a traditional war
against Russia's much Superior
um technical abilities I mean those
missile attacks on Ukrainian
installations
um the aviation that Russia had that's
not something Ukraine can compete with
but lots of people are saying that they
are willing to fight this out it's going
to be more kind of dual kind of
resistance campaign in starts early to
kind of give too much uh thought to that
for now but definitely you know people
here are aware of the of the the needs
to try try and not fight Russia on its
own terms because Ukraine's giving it
giving you a weaker Technical Resources
obviously set up to fail in that kind of
scenario but for now no sense of token
kind of collapse of panic but more just
of dread I think over the last few
months we had those pretty alarmist uh
headlines coming out of Washington
coming out of London and for the longest
time people here in Ukraine didn't
really want to believe it I think you
know people just thought this was Bluff
this was brinkmanship they didn't
actually think Logan Putin would go
through with it or if they thought but
uh at worst there would be an escalation
in in the East indomback but they didn't
think there would be a full scale in
Beijing along all of Ukraine the borders
as we've seen now happening today so
that's definitely more and uh animal
threatening scenarios and people have
prepared for but people are now are
still functioning still uh trying to
help each other I've seen people trying
to organize petrol for their neighbors
to help them get out helping people with
generators
Distributing supplies so now and it can
be small town where I am not all that
panic
Nick thanks so much for now that was our
correspondent Nick Connelly there
reporting from Northeastern Ukraine
outside of the cities of the country's
largest city car key
well let's cross over to Washington now
our correspondent there uh is Stefan
Simmons he's standing by Stefan uh
President Biden has said the world will
hold Russia accountable for this attack
he's expected to address the nation on
Thursday what how can we expect the U.S
to react
yeah it's going to address Americans
tomorrow at noon local time here and
what he is expected to do and to deliver
there is he will announce a more and
more severe sanctions against uh Russia
and that means in two areas that is uh
the financial Market the access for
Russia to International financial
markets the United States allies and
partners will do it there utmost
probably to prevent all of this from
happening to really isolate
Russia financially and economically
financially as as best as possible
secondly is of course export and import
restrictions
um Russia is the it was in 2021 the
second largest oil exporter into the
United States this will probably also
stop and with that um there's where we
leaving the international stage and go a
little bit into internal policies here
in politics
um he has to prepare the American people
for something what they call here what
we call here a sticker shock and this is
um if this is all going to happen like
this if the United States there the
European allies and partners are ramping
up and increasing in intensity sanctions
against Russia as they have promised
they do as Mr Putin or President Putin
escalates the situation there then this
has consequences economically and in
terms of convenience for Americans
probably also for Europeans gas prices
will rise etc etc and other some other
inconveniences so this is going to be
expected tomorrow but for of course the
focus of the American
policy makers here and the Biden
Administration is to make sure everybody
understands that America its allies and
partners stands with Ukraine and
standing with Ukraine has means clearly
no boots on the ground no troops in the
Ukraine but economic Stark Stark dark
and severe
economic sanctions against Russia
well the U.N security Council has
convened for an emergency meeting that
was a few hours ago just before the
reports of the invasion U.N Secretary
General Antonio gutaris addressed
President Putin directly let's hear what
he had to say
so
if indeed an operation is being prepared
I have only one thing to say
from the bottom of my heart
President Putin
stop your troops from attacking the
Ukraine
Give Peace a chance to many people have
already died
the U.N Secretary General Antonio
Gutierrez there well Stefan uh in
Washington Ukraine has urged the U.N to
do whatever it can to stop the war can
the U.N do anything to stop this war
Stefan
no clear and simple no the UN cannot the
U.N security Council uh it cannot this
is more bark than bite it's always like
this the U.N security Council is a forum
where those big Powers those five
permanent members are supposed to
discuss and find Solutions and then you
have 10 non-permanent members sitting in
this U.N security Council and this a few
hours ago as you mentioned there was
Russia got its earful I mean there was a
really almost nobody
not pointing towards Russia and saying
like President Putin and Russia is a
sole aggressor here and there was some
emotional and quite rambunctious scenes
when the Ukrainian Ambassador
um really put the put almost like the
pistol to the chest of the Russian
Ambassador who at the U.N who has right
now the presidency the chair of the U.N
security Council and saying like okay
come on tell me are you not bombarding
now our cities or sending missiles into
into Odessa or kkf or in other cities
This Is War isn't it say it make a call
to foreign minister to your boss Sergey
lavrov of course the Russian ambassador
to the UN did not engage in any of this
he didn't call his boss
foreign minister lavrov and of course he
said well this is just a special
military operation not a war however
just hours later it looks a little bit
different than just a special military
operation
okay now the timing of Vladimir Putin's
address
was significant it happened in this I'm
sure was not a coincidence it happened
at the same time that this U.N security
Council meeting was taking place what do
you make of that
yeah I mean
there we leave the the grounds of facts
and go into speculation now symbolic
politics is
um and has opportunities like this and
Vladimir Putin Putin is a master of of
this kind of politicking of sending
messages symbolic messages to his own
clientele to his own people to the
Russians but also into the world so
there is a chance that he really timed
that very well to
um the U.N emergency U.N security
Council meeting there because he knew it
for hours that the uh that the
ukrainians had requested one of course
but on the other hand
um to be also very clear those decisions
are also made and those speeches are are
are held when politicians or Mr Putin in
this case are getting their feedback
from their military commanders on the
ground so there's a little bit of give
and take and
um probably maybe both reasons entitled
him or or forced him to make this speech
at the time however towards the speech
one thing I want to mention the
denetification of Ukraine this was
something and of course also the stock
warnings of Mr Putin against the West
this was understood by the United States
by a lot of experts and Military experts
and observers here very very clearly and
this made everybody listen that Vladimir
Putin is
accusing the government Democratic
democratically elected government of
Ukraine to be Nazis I mean the president
of Ukraine is actually Jewish
so Americans and American ears they
popped up here there that left quite a a
mark for attention uh in American
circles here in circles here in
Washington and the same goes of course
for the uh blatant uh threat against the
West not to engage in any way or form
militarily
Stefan thank you very much for now
Stefan zema is our correspondent there
in Washington
you are watching DW news from Berlin
this is a special edition focusing on
the Russian attack that is taking place
right now on Ukraine it appears to be a
full-scale attack Russia has launched
what it calls a military operation in
Ukraine it appears to be the start of a
new war in Europe U.S President Joe
Biden has condemned what he called an
unjustified and unprovoked attack here
in Germany Chancellor Olaf short said it
was a terrible day for Ukraine and a
dark day for Europe President Vladimir
Putin announced the move in a surprise
TV address shortly before 6 a.m Moscow
time he warned the world that any
attempt to interfere would lead to quote
consequences you have never seen
Ukraine says that Russia has launched a
full-scale invasion of the country
Ukrainian leader Vladimir zielinski said
Russia was attacking military
infrastructure throughout the country
and Border guards he urged citizens not
to panic and said Ukraine would Prevail
explosions have been heard in several
Ukrainian cities including Kiev and
kharkiv in the east
while Ukraine's president oladimir
zielinski addressed his people with an
emotive speech here's what he had to say
the ukrainians this morning President
Putin announced a special military
operation in the donbus Russia carried
out strikes on our military
infrastructure on our border guards
explosions were heard in many cities of
Ukraine we are introducing martial law
throughout the state a minute ago I had
a conversation with President Biden the
U.S is starting to gather international
support
today we need each of you each of you to
become if possible stay at home please
we are working the Army is working the
entire security and defense sector of
Ukraine is working I the National
Security and defense Council the
government will be in touch soon I will
be in touch again don't panic we are
strong we are ready for everything and
we will defeat everyone because we are
Ukraine glory to Ukraine
foreign
telling them not to panic Thomas Sparrow
our political correspondent is with me
here in the studio Thomas what do you
make of what uh what we're hearing from
baladimir zielinski he of course has
been calling on Germany to provide more
assistance in the lead-up to this um how
how are where do relations stand between
Germany and Ukraine now that this
conflict has begun well in fact zelensky
and German Chancellor Olaf Schultz have
just spoken on the phone the message we
heard there from the German government
was that they were expressing their full
solidarity towards Ukraine something
that they have already expressed in the
past as well it's important really to
mention that Germany has through various
means official and not official ways
expressed that it's standing by Ukraine
and is ready to assist in different ways
and when we look at assistance that's
where the key Point here comes in
because Germany differs from other
Ukrainian allies when it comes to the
way in which it has assisted so
countries within NATO for example have
decided to send defensive weapons to
Ukraine Germany has clearly stated on
various occasions that it's not in a
position to do that they did however
send a 5 000 helmets to Ukraine only
stay announced they were going to send
those 5 000 helmets which was a direct
request by Kiev that was already some
time ago and it was met with criticism
by by Ukrainian leaders for example the
mayor in Kiev Italy klich so Germany's
position there differs from the position
of other NATO allies Germany had stress
has stress on time and time again they
will probably do so in the next few days
and in the next few weeks is that
they're helping Ukraine mostly through
economic ways that Germany is one of the
key economic
help us if you will of Ukraine in that
sense and that the key to increase that
Aid we've also heard from the Ukrainian
Ambassador here in Berlin with a list of
what he believes Germany should be doing
and he specifically stressed the need
for defensive weapons
very unlikely that it's going to happen
but I do expect a debate within the
German political parties to see whether
that could be the case and all of this
of course in the idea of delivering
anything to the current Ukrainian
government is predicated on the idea
that that government will hold
absolutely the attack that is taking
place right now from Russia is not going
to uh is not going to displace the
government that is currently there in
Ukraine that we don't end up with some
sort of Russia moscow-controlled
government in Kiev which appears to be
Vladimir Putin's goal
um just to just quickly Thomas many are
concerned here in Germany at least about
the gas supply now that this conflict
has has escalated to this point uh we've
already seen Germany suspend the
certification of the north stream to
pipeline that was to bring gas directly
from Russia to Germany that would appear
to be as one commentator described just
a chunk of metal under the Baltic at
this point
Germany relies on I think more than half
of its gas supplies from Russia Europe
as a whole gets 40 percent of its gas
supplies from Russia could we end up
seeing Europe cut off from Russian gas
supplies well that's certainly what
German leaders are trying to avoid what
European leaders are trying to avoid it
at the same time they're trying
obviously to diversify their energy
sources you asked about what concerns
German having this regard and it's
important there was a new poll which
revealed that Germans actually want
those kinds of economic sanctions that
we are seeing imposed on Russia yet at
the same time they would not be willing
to pay higher costs for goods that come
as a result of those sanctions so there
is a concern here in Germany but also in
other European Capital into the European
countries that all this tense situation
over energy in particular could lead to
higher costs and could lead to economic
difficulty so that's also something that
that German leaders European leaders
have to keep in mind what the impact
could be here at home when they decide
to engage in these different scenarios
with Russia Europe of course scrambling
to look for alternative uh gas supplies
at this point Thomas Sparrow our
political correspondent thanks for now
and let's get some more reactions to
Russia's attack on Ukraine uh by uh this
is Joe Biden the U.S president tweeting
a short time ago that Russia alone is
responsible for the death and
destruction that this attack will bring
and he says the United States and its
allies and partners will respond in a
United and decisive way the world will
hold Russia accountable he says the
European Union's commission president uh
Ursula Funderland says we strongly
condemned Russia's unjustified attack on
Ukraine in these dark hours our thoughts
are with Ukraine and the innocent women
men and children as they face this
unprovoked attack and fear for their
lives she says we will hold the Kremlin
accountable
and this from British prime minister
Boris Johnson I am appalled by the
horrific events in Ukraine and I have
spoken to president zielinski to discuss
next steps President Putin has chosen a
path of Bloodshed and destruction by
launching this unprovoked attack on
Ukraine the UK and our allies will
respond decisively
well our Brussels bureau chief